[Music]
Apple is claiming that samsung copied
iPhone technology to market its own
products while Samsung's vice president
of electronics has already released a
video that's defending his company it's
a video message defending Samsung let's
take a look
hello Apple's claim that Samsung has
copied their technology as an allegation
were vigorously denying since we entered
the personal electronic space Samsung
has created products that as you can see
they're no similarity to happen notice
the grey edge of our galaxy phone and
what about our galaxy tablets not even
close it's not just electronics
Samsung's originality is also on display
in our home appliances whether it's our
new macro wave oven our vac Pro vacuum
cleaner or eye washer wood scroll wheel
control don't believe me then come to
our retail stores where you can talk
more about our products with a Samsung
smart guy
I know a lot of people ask how does
Samsung stay so original so innovative
it's very simple really we stay true to
the vision of Samsung founders to farm
jobs
you